perfetto aspetta aspetta magari mare che
noi conoscendo facendo aspetto che
aspetto di entrarci e 200 all'ora guarda
mai ii aveva un po piccolino lento
nostro figlio spazio che vai cosa ho
visto delle robe strane ma ci siamo
passati lo aveva più di armi ci sei sono
morti quasi morto ma è allungato la
testa contro la ringhiera e sopporta
amiche signore così ma di volte ma non è
vero perché sei morto
penso non possiamo atterrare regalanti
tranquillo mi si allunga al collo cosa
si cela sua faccia è stata bellissima la
tua riesce è stata preziosa proprio ok
ragazzi forse questo e l'altoparlante
dal quale parlava quel tizio rias perché
vedo se riesco a mandare un messaggio a
tutti quanti viva la pizza aveva sentito
a tutti è così mi ha sentito sono andato
all'altoparlante disistima la pizza è
viva la pizza gaia
enjoy ma allora io non vorrei
sbilanciarmi mandare mancando di aver
trovato l'arma più forte del gioco può
essere preso di lanciarmi come dice
secondo me abbiamo vinto ha ucciso un
sacco di esseri umani io con quella
bomba di questi qua dovrebbero essere
morti
non ho capito chi ha vinto octo del
majlis ai rus praticamente proviamo a
vedere che cosa esce fuori da sta roba
non prometto niente
no non ci credo non ci credo non ci
credo non ci credo
zitti cos'è voglio vedere la parola
pisanello
insomma
forse
ti prego no di subito
ma non c'è la palla a sono io eh no
vabbè falso il ritardo di questa via a
due stadi è chiesta bene di frutta
benissimo
vamos a la playa così perché stai
veramente cagando vale ottimale proprio
una sega guarda notò stato io non so
stato di giuro che cattivo che cosa hai
fatto non si fa cattivo to the kid ha
fatto crescere strozzi e tu che guardi
si va di lei che quel casino si affermo
che tutto e va beh non c'era niente che
ragione bisogna umani tale mi entra
ma lei è scemo io ti guardo ma non
c'entro anch'io
guarda che veloci 4 chiuso ma si chiude
si chiude faccia uscire mi faccio uscire
ma che schifo io non è scavalco mai no
signor gattino dei problemi arrivano
spesso si ragazzo faccia velo signor
gatto signor gatto signor gatto spari
signor gatto anno vi devo fare strada
tema non sono anche dobbiamo andare non
ho seguito niente se segui mixo io dove
andare credo fortemente che non dovesse
andare così mi capisce questo non è il
gioco perfetto che questa veramente figo
altro che all
e tutti gli altri altre cagate di prima
questo in gioco figo se io non fossi tu
milan e soffioni per in una famiglia di
fratelli che lo odia la seconda direi
senza il mio mandato i cadetti ha senso
e non si sia presa e che te lo si apre
fare di piace ma ma che cazzo dici marco
che abbiamo provato di vedere all il
tono marco cose ti stiamo registrando un
video con ruber più filo d'italia e fa
vj e stavamo parlando di te di un mio
ipotetico abusare di tele sessualmente
vorrei sapere un tuo ipotetico godere se
stai alle tombe cioè come prestito con
la voce di ciò che sto trattando bene al
netto fare un figlio
più che altro figlio non poco e non
verso la cosa mi del titolo perché non è
stato attivato veloce grande e bello che
ci sta bene è bellissimo porto numero 3
perché era questo adesso tu il suo
interno che mi spieghi perché questa è
la porta numero 3 come 1222 non tra i 23
perché dove lo vedi il 3 dove minchia
sta il 3 questa è una c abc ho capito
[Musica]
sì no no no no no no no no no no no no
ti ammazzo vi uccido la famiglia ragazzi
no io ho scaricato questa demo perché
voglio divertirmi non per fare ste
cagate prove senta lei non si fissano le
foto degli altri lo sa e non si
indossano questi pigiami bruttissimi
ecco perfetta ma quanto fiero
sono veramente pronto a qualsiasi cosa
no questa ragazza e una mappa che
conosco benissimo perché ho avuto
episodi piacevoli ma la macchina non
hanno avuto prima sperimentarle
chiedermelo mentre veniva investita mi
sembra un'ottima su cup
ok boschi focoso visto che posso ho
visto ma jin yo yo è oggi giulio allora
tra tutti i ruoli il portiere quello che
mi si addice di meno paga enna
a cosa serve sta roba mi sto facendo
malissimo alla mano ma non fa niente
amore cosa stai scrivendo su quel foglio
lì non puoi semplicemente darmi una mano
visto che io non ho mani questo è
hamburger salsa di polipo praticamente
c'è su quanto difficile fare poi non
avrò mai figli polipi e tra l'altro la
cosa che devi fare è cercare di seguire
l'andamento della pista però non andare
addosso le macchine almeno il triciclo
intatto almeno quello pietro no
pietro non è il triciclo si arrivi che
prova senza pietro va benissimo era era
lui il problema ha capito senza pietre
fattibilissima
questa roba è lui che ha un peso
specifico sbagliato guardano di quanto
triste eder bravo pietro
ciao amici sono con degli altri amici e
uno e ciccio l'altro e thomas stiamo per
giocare bene possiamo partire di
provocare ok sposati comunque descrivi
la tua adolescenza in tre parole però
deve censurare sia mica che che sono
invendibili token berg questo non
l'avevo ancora provato questa era
proprio quello dei vecchi tempi per chi
seguiva tripodi smonta i tempi c'è la
sta macchina che era bellissima ultimo
ara e la migliore per sfuggire dalla
polizia
guardali guardali tutti uccellati nel
vero senza una parola guarda guarda non
mi prendo il mite neanche lupin un genio
ma ti prego non escono sempre un sacco
di rottami che ora grande porta li
portano però è questo qua li potevi
cinema perché lecce l'isola che butta
paga adesso no no jack ti prego morendo
vance
[Musica]
un elicottero vai vai vai subito ma non
sapevo esistesse parla veloce pelle
colorata e lo sapremo mai
forse ce l'ha ma cascata nell'altro
l'hanno incastrato si forma spostarlo
con la macchina
noi voglio voglio vederlo conclude
ringrazio anch'io spostato la matrice
sparo ma mi sa che erano le eliche che
sbattevano contro allora spettacolari
corse no no gazzanelli che ci stanno
parandosi dalla dalla roccia della
russia francia 105 diamo andarsene non
si può muovere l'elicottero salta 60 60
sub ti sei mai k scappa
manicone eve centro vano per quelli
sempre stata in aria la chiava fuoco ma
bello salta fuori
amici miei spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto
questa era una priorità normalissima
uguale alla mano ma le tue gocciola ma
pronta ma niente facciamo il tiro 10 mg
giorno malore
[Musica]